Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P..
I have to tell you, I don't really understand
this caller.
I'm going to play this for you.
Maybe we can figure it out together.
Speaker 3: Yes, this is Dr. Famagusta,
Speaker 5: and I was horrified.
Speaker 1: I don't know what's up with the
audio, by the way.
I'm aware of it
Speaker 5: at your comments about that clip
pupate.
You played with it with comments about art
and mask wearing.
I just really blew me away and left me wondering
what you spend your spare time researching.
I can only hope.
That in the future, you don't have a clip.
Where somebody claims that mass cannot reverse.
Almost sexual intercourse.
Commander David.
Speaker 1: There anybody have any idea what
that's about?
Like, I don't even know what segment it relates
to because we talk about masks and I don't
know, it's a very, very strange voicemail.
If anybody has even the slightest inkling
what that might be about, please let me know.
On today's bonus show, we will be talking
about Hurricane Ida, which hit the Gulf Coast
as a Category four storm.
Cash shortages at ATMs, gas shortages.
You can't get cash to buy gas that isn't there
any way to get out people in dire, dire circumstances
in Louisiana and elsewhere.
We will discuss that.
Reports of cheating at colleges have exploded
during the pandemic.
Part of it is sort of intuitive.
If there's a lot of work from home and test
from home stuff happening, it's easier to
cheat.
But is there something else to it psychologically
going on, making people more willing to cheat
during covid?
We will talk about that on today's bonus show.
And then lastly, many of you requesting this
story.
And when the people ask for it, I will oblige.
Disgraced right wing darling Milo Yiannopoulos
not only has covid, but apparently has been
injecting himself with a dosage of ivermectin
meant for livestock.
And even looking at the picture of the syringe
that Milo posted, it looks like a pretty wide
gauge syringe that it doesn't look like that
thin covid vaccine syringe.
I don't know how many needle, rather.
I don't know how many of you have seen.
I don't many of you have.
You've gotten vaccinated.
If you didn't look away when you were getting
the coveted vaccine, the needle is incredibly
thin.
It's a notably it's almost a perfect needle.
I would say the needle that Milo posted is
quite a thick gauge and I don't know what
the hell is going on, but we're going to talk
about the latest with Milo and ivermectin
and his covid and just whether he's trying
to use this to mount another comeback.
I actually recently engaged I had a very,
very brief email back and forth with Milo
a few months ago before he got covid.
I will talk a little bit about that.
And then we will also talk about the what
we believe is the resolution to last week's
tech issues.
I have some updates on that.
I got some very important suggestions from
people in the audience.
So that's all today on the bonus show.
I want to remind you, we may be as little
as 24 hours.
From reaching one billion YouTube views on
our YouTube on our main YouTube channel, one
billion YouTube views, it is an incredible
milestone.
In a sense, it's more impressive than a million
subscribers.
And I will talk about why once we reach the
milestone, we have a beautiful video plan
that producers put together for us along with
help from NOAA.
And and it's a great video we've got.
It's cued up and ready to go when we get to
that billion.
And we will also have a fantastic membership
special go out to our newsletter subscribers
when we get to that billion views.
So make sure you're signed up at David Pakman
Dotcom.
But before any of that, today's bonus shows
join me there.
I will see you at.